l'intervention de vladimir poutine était
largement consacré au thème de cette
édition du club valdaï à savoir la
pandémie et ses conséquences sur le
monde d'après il a mis en avant la
nécessité du dialogue que ce soit dans
un cadre internationale au niveau de
l'onu et en particulier le conseil de
sécurité ou bien dans un cadre plus
régionale comme par exemple le format
d'astana sur la syrie ou encore
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai le débat qui a suivi son
discours il a également abordé le thème
du contrôle des armements stratégiques
mais aussi et pour la première fois la
sphère navalni l'a donc appris que c'est
vladimir poutine personnellement qui a
autorisé l'opposant russe a quitté le
territoire de la russie
malgré les restrictions de déplacements
dus à la fermeture des frontières et
comme de nombreux responsables russes
avant lui il a pointé du doigt certaines
incohérences de l'enquète et regretté le
manque de coopération des autorités
allemandes
qu avons nous demandé de si spécial
le parquet général a envoyé à plusieurs
reprises des demandes officielles afin
que nous soient transmis ces matériaux
conformément à nos accords avec
l'allemagne qu'y a t'il d'exceptionnel
là dedans
de plus j'ai suggéré lors d'une de mes
conversations avec un dirigeant européen
que nos spécialistes viennent en
allemagne avec des spécialistes français
et allemand et suédois
nous aurions pu travailler ensemble sur
place nous aurions pu obtenir des
matériaux pour les utiliser comme base
pour ouvrir une affaire pénale
et s'il s'agit vraiment d'un événement
criminel il faudrait mener une enquête
mais il ne nous donne rien comment
pourriez vous l'expliquer il n'y a pas
d'explication
pas d'explication c'est étrange ce qui
se passe alors qu'il reste d'après le
président russe de nombreuses zones
d'ombré dans cette affaire les
conséquences elles sont bien tangibles à
savoir le renforcement des sanctions
européennes existantes contre la russie
mais aussi l'adoption de nouvelles
restrictions à l'encontre de plusieurs
personnes physiques et morales des
mesures qui éloigne un peu plus les pays
les uns des autres alors qu'au contraire
le président russe a pendant tout son
discours martelé la nécessité
d'améliorer la confiance entre les pays
par le dialogue et ce sur tous les
sujets